617 830 for 750 we will take our next
call hopefully a better connection this
time name in town were you calling from
um Paul my name's Paul and i'm calling
from Virginia Beach what can we do for
you Paul um I'd a question I was
wondering but you've been going on about
how the a potential trump presidency or
loss would cause like a polarization in
the Republican Party I was wondering
your thoughts which I don't think many
people have like talking about uh what
what do you think Congress on both
parties would do if he's president
because it's been reservations from
people like Paul Ryan and even Mike
Pence last night trying to defend him um
like would like would they even listen
like I'm just thinking of like something
that he could say or do those so
egregious that they just would not back
in yet will this enemy ok so if Trump
wins which we all hope doesn't happen uh
did the the Democratic Party I am sure
would become obstructionist and they
would try to prevent uh any extremist or
crazy things that Trump might do from
happening now you have to remember a lot
of the ideas Crump throws around during
the campaign they're either
unconstitutional or violations of
existing policy or law and it's not even
going to be up to Congress as to whether
to undo it always just sort of not going
to happen I think the more interesting
question around there on the Republican
side where but notably Mitch McConnell
McConnell and Paul Ryan the Senate
Majority Leader and Speaker of the House
respectively they've basically
disappeared over the last few weeks they
clearly want nothing to do with anything
that's going on more than likely if
Trump were to win they would be engaged
in so far as trying to do there you know
so-called small government a show that
they do in passing bills to cut welfare
spending in social programs and this
type of thing
and they would have you know a serious
conversation about what is the plan in
2020 do we even try to get Trump
re-elected or do we just try to
negotiate that Trump leave after one
term I think you would see a faction of
the Republican Party some which would
say hey I don't want to get left behind
I'm going to do whatever it is that I
need to do to be in Trump's good graces
and then others who would say I don't
agree with this the those would be
probably the more principled Republicans
or the ones that are just way more
conservative than Trump and find him to
be too far to the left but I think it'll
be very very interesting thank you for
the call i do appreciate it we do have
to move on